[Musique]
m
bonjour messieurs les vertes
bonjour bijoux merci d'être ici sur le
plateau de tv 78 pour ce vide qui vous
est entièrement consacré et vous êtes en
pleine actualité là vous êtes en tournée
les vertes et on a une chance
énorme parce que vous avez un lien avec
les yvelines déjà vous êtes de la celle
saint cloud est ce qu'on peut dire que
vous êtes frais ou faut pas le dire
non non on peut le dire ainsi mais voilà
on ne sait si elle n'est pas de la c25
l'ougandais frère joue pas dimanche ni
en bretagne ou à supporter juillet dans
4 nages montrait bien vous avez habité
certains dans la celle saint cloud et
surtout vous avez un passé versaillais
car il a très longtemps
les punks étaient présents à versailles
on est d'accord on avait vingt ans même
pas aller un peu plus de 30 ans voilà
j'ai déjà 35 ans sandra cuillère et vous
étiez déjà musicien l'époque
ouais ouais alors qu'est ce que vous
faisiez vous monsieur paulo parce que je
voudrais pas présenté donc nous avons
paulo nous avons mathieu des
vertes ça c'est dit c'est clair c'est
carré donc vous vous étiez musicien je
te le dis oui à l'époque déjà et je
faisais ou qui s'appelait m les naître
ouais c'était vachement bien
cet hébergeur de cold wave ouais c'était
bien inspiré joy de joy division quoi
décor bien inspiré le joy division et on
a joué on a fermé mena même jouer je
fais des concerts à versailles là c'est
sa hausse est 3ème à l'époque je peux
c'est existe toujours cette salle je me
devrais je sais pas mais la salle oms
est 3ème c'était là et puis en effet la
mjc de porchefontaine on avait fait
quelques trucs quoi et quand même
et à la fontaine des nouettes aussi
approche où je vous revois les gens
placent aujourd'hui festival voilà et
vous jouiez de quoi l'époque paulo moi
je vais de la basse mais le groupe était
un peu spécial c'est à dire qu'ils
étaient deux baptistes qui avait pas de
guitare d'accord ces batteries de base
et un chant d'accord donc les maîtres
les maîtres voilà et vous alors mathieu
vous étiez aussi musicien les ports hdmi
new cities enfants vie du musicien dans
toute la ville où nous mais je vais
là-bas déjà joué là une chouette michel
gondry avec tout semblait aussi et
whisky et odile charrie etienne charry
et vos problèmes
je crois que je suis le premier bassiste
de oui oui aux formidables ici mais on
s'est fait virer avec lui shell jouer
comme je sais nager
non non c'est parce que le groupe en
parallèle qui nous intéressait plus
c'est que avec michèle qui est excellent
et merci merci merci ca y compris celle
ci est donc laitiers nous accueillir et
décors mais par où tu vas récupérer
michel l'est pas moins on ne saura
jamais les des mystères comme ça bon
c'est pas très grave l'important c'est
que nous voulons vous ai récupéré là ce
soir enfin aujourd'hui pour ce pour ce
vide parce que vous êtes en pleine actu
vous êtes
en tournée pour les vertes les
vertes elles ont démarré en
1900 pas les vertes mais votre
premier album la date de 1988 il est
sorti en janvier 89 d'accord et on a
enregistré en fin fin 88 est il sorti en
janvier 89
ok donc là ça fait juste 30 ans ça fait
juste une toile voilà et c'est reparti
pour un tour apparemment voilà qu'est cp
c'est un peu un c'est un peu un concours
circonstances en même temps voilà il ya
eu il ya eu le fait que tous les albums
se re sorte de label because
ressort tous les albums donc une faille
du tout les abonnés du été mis en vente
il ya une boîte de prod qui s'appelle le
décibel production et pierre-alexandre
verte alliés qui nous a proposé de
reprendre de reprendre la route
à l'occasion des 30 ans puis nous voilà
l'occasion et 30 ans une fait-on fêtons
les 30 ans de en fait qu'il dit l'idée
de fêter les 30 ans de l'album là c'est
une idée de michel le trompettiste parce
que reprendre la route oui mais on vous
voyez pas bien bon pour faire quoi pour
refaire faire refaire
et puis l'idée de fête ses 30 ans de cet
album loud
ça nous a plu des cordes donc voilà on a
on a décidé de le faire ok il faut
savoir que l'aîné gaza se sont arrêtés
en 2001 en 2001 voilà et quand vous avez
arrêté vous êtes dit quoi vous vous êtes
dit salut à bientôt adieu à jamais non
c'est pas dire on a en a pas on n'a pas
été bon on n'a pas arrêté complètement
on avait on n'avait pas de guide et
vraiment on savait qu'on avait des
envies d'ailleurs
oui mais
on n'a pas arrêté le groupe on n'a pas
non c'est pas dit bon on arrête on
montera plus jamais sur scène ses filles
est derrière définitif non il n'y a rien
de définitif
d'accord donc vous avez six albums à
votre actif si je me trompe pas 4 du
temps dell nos quillan 2 du temps et
nous sommes alors je suis parti pour des
grosses bêtises ce soir donc de pardon
et après d'autres qui sont sortis et
encore deux albums studio un album de
remixes qu'elle est vachement bien
d'ailleurs lequel alors de l'album de
remixes il s'appelle il s'appelle leur
remix 93 d'accord qui est vachement bien
qu'elle va je me dis ça pour les gens il
est vachement bien ouais c'est un bon
album de remixes on est surtout c'est
qu'on a été les premiers
les premiers français conclut en coupe
d'europe français à faire d'eux des
remixes et elles seront mises aux bills
à mouchin des premières au mix français
qui ait vraiment eu du succès quoi alors
j'ai envie de rafraîchir les mémoires
avec un extrait de celui la mouche si
vous êtes d'accord bon bah dites moi oui
un tout à fait complètement money
[Musique]
thomas
piqué
la gauche tous les jours
me
[Musique]
voilà souvent de soi se souvient c'est
génial c'est clair c'est une bonne
époque une bonne époque
alors après en 2001 qu'est ce que vous
avez fait en quelques mots paulo vous
êtes resté dans la musique je suis resté
dans la musique mais pas je suis d'abord
parti j'ai quitté paris
déjà parce que j'en avais besoin normal
et puis 15 ans de la grèce vers c'était
un peu assez c'était quand même assez
épuisant
ouais vous dire ce qui est et donc moi
je suis parti je suis parti vivre
pendant dix ans sur plateau du larzac
ok j'avais pas de chef surtout là-bas il
y en a pas de façon cd 1er mai mais j'ai
fait de la musique
ouais j'ai fait de la musique j'ai fait
deux guides j'ai pas mal j'ai fait j'ai
écrit beaucoup et j'ai lu beaucoup et
j'ai marché aussi beaucoup d'accords et
c'était une bonne période c'était
vraiment dix ans et que je rejette à
refaire je ferais lisant nécessaire
vraiment ouais je suis permis après j'ai
permis et après ça après ses 10 ans là
je suis également partie mois à l'opposé
je suis parti dans le nord pas de calais
avec une compagnie de théâtre s'appelle
accompagné de l'embardée cdd des vieux
comme un bras qui font ça depuis des
années et j'ai fait donc du théâtre
pendant trois ans on a fait du théâtre
mais pas que si je continuais la musique
et après je crois savoir que vous êtes
allé chez m
quand on est chez bartabas voilà pendant
deux ans j'ai pas du spread su alors
pardon bah moi gérard était plutôt que
paulo moi je suis me suis arrêté après
le deuxième album des corps est là avec
que jo on l'a fondé un big band qui
s'appelle tarass boulba tard est bien
sûr que jouer
donc toutes les terres du monde après et
puis et puis après j'ai été père au
foyer
d'accord j'ai élevé mes enfants et puis
après j'ai migré vers la toile toujours
en faisant toujours la musique parce que
malheureusement basse et je crains des
ouais bien sûr ça oui je fais pas je
suis comme tous les musiciens je ne
sachant rien faire je suis un homme à
tout faire très bien donc j'ai fait tous
les métiers du monde des cas mais
surtout essentiellement la musique comme
ça me nourrissais et puis et puis voilà
vous êtes parti pardon je vous coupe la
parole ce travail élevée 18 mai
l'émission est très courte et donc là
vous êtes parti pour une tournée qui a
duré tout l'été qui dure encore là et
vous avez deux dates les 12 et 13
octobre au cabaret sauvage
vous avez fait un paquet de festival
vous êtes aussi le 1er février à
l'olympia
exact voilà et et vous donc vous jouer
l'album bla vous avez répété j'imagine
pour vous remettre dans le bain et puis
là c'est parti vous retrouvez votre
public quel est votre public
actuellement bal public il a pas il a il
a changé évidemment aimé moi je
m'attends fin on s'attendait tous plus
ou moins avoir des gens plus de 40 ans
quand même don bigg majoritairement
40-42 voilà par exemple mais en fait non
en fait il s'est avéré que surtout dans
les festivals mais le monstre c'est pas
très étonnant parce que dans les
festivals les gens et viennent pas
forcément pour vous voir
ouais viennent pour voir un groupe où
plusieurs groupes et puis vous découvre
dit le qu'on a eu un public de jeunes on
a été découvert un public de jeunes qui
ne connaissaient à huy qui nous
connaissaient et qu'ils ne connaissaient
pas ou par leurs parents
mais qui connaissait et qui connaissait
certains titres d'accord comme le seuil
de bodega voilà l'été et qui connaissait
mais c'est des chansons qui en même
temps jamais vraiment quitté les radios
écoles accueilli surtout envie parce que
je ne savais pas que vous étiez
précurseur vous avez quand même me
mélanger tout un type de musique le rail
la musique espagnole
la guinguette vous avez est ce qu'on
peut dire déringardiser l'accordéon
enfin tout ça c'est c'était très en
avance vous avez des textes engagés sur
des chansons gaies des textes pas
forcément guerre il par exemple
voilà donc mieux culture soit guère par
seul cri page de fans
quoique pas tout mais c'est généralement
il est généralement les textes pendant
sont un peu tristes on est d'accord sur
des rythmes endiablés et entraînant
voilà voilà donc c'est une recette parce
que ça marche très bien et là vous allez
terminer votre tournée tout le monde
vous demande alors qu'en est il la
prochaine album mais je sais que c'est
pas encore dans les tuyaux non c'est pas
encore dans les tuyaux s'interdit rien
on sa teinte et rien non non non ne
s'interdit rien mais là c'est pas le but
du jeu le but du jeu c'est de faire ce
qu'on a des gators qu'on a dit qu'on
ferait c'est-à-dire aurait joué cet
album sur scène pendant là au moins
c'est 2 années avait carrément après sa
sortie le 19 juin le rien mais j'ai rien
mais on a passé du temps jusqu'en
septembre 2019
on fait des concerts ou des concerts
mais et après bah bien pouvoir
ouais d'accord vous avez quand même un
documentaire qui va peut-être sortir
parce que quelqu'un vous quelqu'un qui
sait pas mais bon c'est quand on a passé
1 536 fr est tout à fait un livre et je
veux bien qu'on voie un extrait alors
dans ce cas là voilà c'est parti avec
plaisir
[Musique]
gagner nous sont inondées
il
[Musique]
salué les
la main
à
ce clip c'est raymond depardon c'est des
images et les photos c'est un montage de
photos d'un monsieur raymond depardon et
c'était ou à beyrouth
là où vous avez on a joué vous avez joué
c'était un des premiers concerts après
l'âge c'était le chat est là le premier
concert après la guerre d'accord voilà
nous on a joué là bas c'était le cessez
le feu avait eu lieu quelques mois
précédemment précédent la ville et la
ville était alors oui je vous avais
plein moment très fort ouais ouais ouais
j'ai fort avec ses collaborations avec
madonna avec massive attack quelque
chose vous êtes mais oui c'est autre
chose ça n'a rien à voir mais tout est
important aussi et vous êtes très connu
à l'étranger
très apprécié vous avez vendu 350 mille
albums à l'étranger et donc voilà on
vous souhaite bon vent bah ouais échange
des 10 agents qui est puis fait bien ce
que vous avez envie de faire savoir cet
album là et et prions pour que
l'inspiration et l'envié soit avec vous
oui bien sûr à très vite on extrapole du
bruit merci beaucoup
pas très vite 3
[Musique]